russia and the united states have
conducted a prisoner swap after lengthy
negotiations russia's foreign ministry
says a former u.s marine held in a
russian jail trevor reed has been
swapped for one of its citizens serving
a 20-year sentence in the u.s
well the white house has released a
statement by president joe biden he says
the negotiations that allowed us to
bring trevor home required difficult
decisions that i do not take lightly
let's go straight to our white house
correspondent kimberly hulkett so
kimberly the u.s waking up to the news
and biden already commenting on it
yeah that's right this is a case that
the white house and according to a
senior administration official from the
state department has been working on for
months
we know that there have been behind the
scenes negotiations in terms of staff of
the state department and the russian
government that have been meeting for
some time and we are learning more about
how this took place what we know is that
there has been a lengthy negotiation
process that led to this prisoner
exchange we don't know exactly where it
took place there are some reports this
may have occurred
in ankara turkey but again these are
unconfirmed reports
we do know that this exchange was for a
russian convicted drug trafficker by the
name of constantin yaroshenko
who was arrested in liberia in 2010 for
allegedly smuggling cocaine
into that country uh and what we also
know is that this has been a case that
has been on the minds of the american
who has been released uh the marine uh
that this is something that has been uh
certainly an effort of his family to
bring him home for some time
there has been a protest by this family
in front of the white house and it is
something that uh led to a meeting with
the president very recently and perhaps
even escalated this in the minds of the
president uh leading perhaps to this
release what we can tell you is that
the family had been very concerned about
his condition and his health his family
says that in recent weeks he had and
months he had contracted tuberculosis he
had been in solitary confinement he had
been working in prison camps and they
were gravely concerned that if he
continued in detention that he may not
make it back to the united states
following his release he had been
sentenced for 19 years for allegedly
assaulting a police officer something
the family denies
according to a senior administration
official we now know that he is on his
way home
somewhat surprising is it kimberly when
relations between the us and russia are
so sour at the moment
indeed and let me just cough first we've
got a lot of pollen here for the
springtime and all the flowers are
blooming so i can get through this
answer
okay all right
you're right it's absolutely uh some
challenging times for the united states
and russia right now uh
we've got a very heightened rhetoric you
have to remember that just this week
we've had the russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov
threatening nuclear war the defense
minister of the united states or rather
defense secretary lloyd austin uh saying
that this is not helpful rhetoric
calling this bluster that needs to
de-escalate uh the the stakes have never
been higher but in the midst of all of
this there are still these negotiations
and that is because the white house and
even the russian federation has said for
some time that they believe there is
still this need to keep talking uh even
as there is this threat of nuclear
confrontation looming both sides know
that that is a fight that nobody wins
and so while there is this heightened
rhetoric and fear
there is still this diplomatic dialogue
that continues and so as a result
this is an example of that but having
said that there are still americans that
are detained in russia
there are still russians that are
detained in the united states and so one
can only presume that these talks will
continue because it is in the interest
of both governments to see both of these
sides having these
respective citizens returned absolutely
well kimberly we appreciate you keeping
on talking as well please do go and get
some water now kimberly hellcutt
reporting from washington